Google cloud next 2017 hosted a plethora
of talks detailing the future of cloud
if you didn't get a chance to catch
building service applications with
Google cloud functions stay tuned
because here's the recap there's a fancy
new phrase in the computing world known
as service applications which might be
just a little misleading see service
doesn't mean not using servers but
instead it means that you don't need to
think about deployment provisioning or
managing of the servers that you're
working in a pay for what you use model
where you deploy functions not apps and
you're working in an event base or vent
oriented model to understand why this is
a helpful idea let's do a recap in a
typical cloud computing application you
have to setup and provision some VMs
which handled traffic the number of VMS
you need is typically a function of
traffic volume and in order to respond
to requests efficiently you typically
have to over provision this leads to
wasted money since you're only using
those resources in spiky scenarios now
recently containers were added to the
concept of cloud computing which allow
you to deploy a container on a VM which
can handle traffic by itself the the
difference here is that as traffic Rises
you can allocate a new container on the
same VM rather than a whole new VM
itself however you end up back in the
same problem if you end up with modulus
overhead between the number of
containers in the number of VMs you have
allocated surplus is another way to
tackle this problem where you break down
your application into the smallest
functions possible you then deploy each
function and give it the ability to
handle capacity then let some other
system handle provisioning and
allocation in order to reduce over
provisioning costs this is exactly the
service that Google Cloud functions
provides it's a service environment to
build and connect services through code
which means that you don't need to think
about servers you only pay for what you
use and it's all event oriented here is
a small example internal and external
services can emit events like changes to
a cloud storage bucket and cloud
functions you've defined will respond to
those events which can right back to the
cloud or call other API so now
developing a cloud function is really
straightforward simply use your existing
knowledge of
Oh DJ s and Express frameworks deploy
your HTTP or background functions and
you're ready to go but the best part
about all this is that cloud functions
come built-in with firebase and stack
driver support which means that you get
access to things like analytics database
access authentication events logging ma
during and even an emulator so you can
develop and test locally rather than in
production check out the recording of
Jason's full session to learn more
details and see some great demos for
moving your existing applications to
Google cloud platform and if you want
more recaps on great next content make
sure to check out the rest of our
playlist and don't forget the next world
tour coming soon to a city near you
[Music]
you